SPEAKER: Business is
booming at Kitty Catwalks.
And meow, with more
customers and employees,
they've got their paws on a
whole lot more sensitive data.
They know that
Google Cloud DLP will
help them protect that
data and reduce their risk.
But with so many
transformation options,
it could be a real challenge
figuring out which ones to use
and when.
Today, we'll talk about
what de-identification
is, the factors to
consider when choosing
a de-identification
technique, and check out
a few examples, including
crypto-based tokenization.
De-identification is
the process of removing
personal identifying
information from your data.
Common examples of personal
identifying information,
or PII, are credit card numbers,
addresses, phone numbers,
and names.
Of course, some
parts of your system
might need access
to this information,
billing for example.
But other parts do not.
This is where de-identification
with DLP comes in.
The DLP API can intelligently
detect sensitive information
and use a number of
de-identification
transformation
techniques to mask,
delete, tokenize, or
otherwise obscure the data.
Choosing the right
de-identification
transformation will depend
largely on two things.
First of all, we're going to
need to consider what kind
of data we want to de-identify.
Are we going to try
to de-identify dates?
By using date shifting,
we can shift date values
by a random amount of time.
Or maybe we're trying to
hide text from images.
Well, image redaction
will work there.
DLP uses info type detectors and
optical character recognition
to find text in image
files and mask it
with an opaque rectangle.
The second thing to
consider is the purpose
for de-identifying data.
This is important, because some
de-identification techniques
will completely hide
sensitive values,
while others will
still allow you
to extrapolate important
information about the data.
Let's consider an example.
Check out this excerpt
from a chat log
between a customer and a Kitty
Catwalks customer service rep.
When we de-identify
it using masking,
the sensitive
content is replaced
by a masking character, like
an asterisk or a hash symbol.
There isn't much that we can
deduce about the information
that's being removed.
When it's de-identified
using replacement,
where it can be replaced
by something else,
like its corresponding
info type,
we can at least know that
what the customer entered
was an email address.
In both cases, we
successfully removed
the personal information.
But with replacement,
we can at least
tell what info type was removed.
Other techniques use bucketing
to help you generalize
distinguishing
values in your data,
based on custom
values or ranges.
This is especially
useful for data
meant to be used for reports
or for data analysis.
We'll be able to
make use of the data
without exposing
it unnecessarily.
For example, when the
finance department
wants to write a
report on salary info,
considering there's only
one director of Cat Naps,
it'd be easy for anyone
looking at this data
to learn what that
person's salary is.
Potentially sensitive
information.
By applying
bucketing here, we're
able to use the financial data
while protecting the employee's
privacy.
Another powerful
de-identification category
worth noting is
crypto-based tokenization.
Cloud DLP can securely
encrypt sensitive data
using a cryptographic
key and replace it
with a hash or a token.
Cloud DLP supports several
types of tokenization,
including some that
are reversible,
so that you can even re-identify
the de-identified data.
Here's one more example.
We scanned some log files of
Kitty Catwalks' issue ticketing
system and exported the
results to BigQuery.
You'll see that,
in the data column,
it shows text that
we've had replacement
applied on various info types.
But check out the first column.
Here, we apply tokenization
and [INAUDIBLE] the user ID.
The values in this column
are unrecognizable.
But if we run a
query like this one
to give us account
based on the user ID,
we can see how many issues
there are for each unique user.
This is accomplished without
exposing the value that we've
replaced, so it can be
used for data analysis
without risk of
compromising user data.
Furthermore, the
user ID values can
be re-identified by
individuals or teams that
are authorized to access the
encryption key used to tokenize
the values in the first place.
So which de-identification
technique
is the best choice
for Kitty Catwalks
to protect their sensitive
customer and employee data?
The good news is
cloud DLP offers
enough de-identification
options and flexibility
that they won't have
to prescribe a blanket
policy for all their PII.
Understanding the
trade-offs of each technique
will empower them to get the
most value from their data,
while protecting it
every step of the way.
Next time, we'll
take a closer look
and examine how some of
these de-identification
transformations work to protect
and secure your sensitive data.
See you then.
[MUSIC PLAYING]